[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us i'm trey gowdy and welcome to
sunday night in america i like fairness
it's why i like golf more than
professional wrestling
and the courtroom more than congress
fairness is
often requires a referee we don't have
to
like the referee but we should be able
to respect
the referee the most recent example of
duplicity and unfairness
is the manner in which congressional
investigations are handled by the
political parties
and the media the d.c media never met a
republican investigation that should
start
or a democrat investigation that should
end
with fast and furious the democrats and
the media
never took an interest you would think
two groups constantly talking about gun
control
would be interested in the u.s aiding
and abetting the flow of guns to mexican
drug cartels
with lois lerner and the irs most
democrats in the media
didn't care about that benghazi
more democrats voted to investigate what
happened in benghazi libya
than republicans voted to investigate
the january
6th attack on the capitol did you know
that
did you know more democrats voted to
form
a select committee to investigate the
deaths
of four americans in libya then
republicans voted
for the january 6th select committee of
course you didn't know that
because the media wants you to believe
one inquiry was a witch hunt
while the other is bipartisan and
serious
and i'm not trying to change your mind
on any of those investigations you're
free to think
they were worth pursuing or not pursuing
i do happen to think what happened on
january the 6th is worthy of
investigation prosecution
and incarceration for those convicted
but regardless of what you think about
the merits of those investigations
i would hope we could all agree the same
standard
the same rules the same process should
apply
to all congressional investigations
regardless of who
is in power the rule should not change
depending on which team is up to bat
and the strike zone should not change
depending on which political party is
conducting the investigation
kevin mccarthy picked five republicans
to populate the january 6th committee
he is the highest ranking republican in
congress and therefore
he picks the republican members but
nancy pelosi rejected two of his picks
she refused to allow them to participate
she summarily deemed them unqualified
and we're not sure why she rejected
leader mccarthy's picks
because the d.c media is too afraid of
her to ask
too afraid to risk losing an interview
too afraid to risk losing sources
too afraid to not be on the receiving
end of a leak
the dc media tells us they speak truth
to power
they tell us democracy dies in darkness
they tell us they publish
all the news that's fit to print and a
host of other
meaningless self-congratulatory
platitudes
but they can't question pelosi on our
own duplicity
when it comes to congressional
investigations
she put adam schiff on the benghazi
committee
even though his mind was fully made up
and he did
everything he could to protect the
democrat nominee for president
that was his job not to interview
survivors
not to access information not to
ascertain while the military didn't
respond in a timely manner
but to protect hillary clinton pelosi
picked him despite his bias
she also picked shift to investigate
donald trump over
russia collusion allegations even though
schiff
misstated evidence prejudged the outcome
and claimed to have evidence he never
produced
she picked shift to lead the prosecution
in a failed impeachment trial even
though schiff
misstated facts misrepresent
misrepresented a meeting with a
whistleblower
and manufactured evidence during a
committee hearing
pelosi picked him anyway pelosi picked
eric swalwell to investigate trump
even though suawell was running for
president
against trump she picked swalwell for
the intelligence committee
despite his close relationship with the
chinese spy
she picked joaquin castro to investigate
trump while his
twin brother was running against trump
for president
she picked democrats on her january 6
select committee
even though they themselves challenged
the 2016 election results
she picked a democrat to investigate
the january 6th attack on the capitol
even though that democrat sued trump
in court nearly 500 people have been
charged
with various crimes related to january
6.
those cases are being investigated by
law enforcement they'll be prosecuted
and sentenced if convicted
there's not a single cop prosecutor or
judge
who would be allowed to remain on those
cases if he or she
did what schiff swalwell castro or the
others
did not one she picked her own bias
members
but she rejected jim jordan jordan
is the top republican on the judiciary
committee
he was on the intelligence committee
which has more access
to more sensitive information than any
committee in congress
jordan has participated in previous
investigations
he worked hard and he didn't leak which
is more than i can say for many of his
colleagues
but whether you like jim jordan or not
is irrelevant
whether you think the previous
investigations or even the current ones
are appropriate
is beside the point congress has the
power and often the responsibility to
investigate
but it should be fair and it's fair to
ask
why democrat members of congress are
free to prejudge evidence
misstate evidence challenge election
results
sue the person they're investigating run
against the person they're investigating
leak-like sieves and yet they're
qualified for service
on an investigative committee but jim
jordan is not
and that's the question why shift and
not jordan
why swalwell and not jordan
why is it your members can have their
minds already made up but somehow that
is disqualifying for the other
side it's the sort of question a serious
objective media would ask
it's the sort of question the media
serious about speaking truth the power
would ask
it's the sort of question a media
devoted to the truth would ask
but the modern media in this country is
just as partisan as the politicians
themselves
truth to power they claim democracy
dies in darkness they claim
well it doesn't do very well in the slew
of hypocrisy either
and that's where we are right now it's
no small part
because the referee is just as partisan
as the players hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else